before we get into the movie i was just
going over your social media and
i saw recently that you posted this
awesome video of you doing this mashup
of three songs
how much has music really helped you and
kept you positive during
you know these really strange times it's
honestly been a lifesaver um
it's kept me it's kept my spirits up and
um
even especially in the early parts of
quarantine the sharing of the music
uh and and nadina you sound awesome and
like this is so cool and like what a
fierce riff but
i think that healing ability that music
has and messaging and
that unspoken feeling you get when you
hear a good song and you're like in a
better mood
um it actually helps the artist too and
and
uh i got reacquainted with my childhood
piano which i
had shipped out many years ago to la and
i was home long enough to really play as
much as i did when i was growing up
um and it inspired me to actually write
my own music
in a real way and like really make an
album
and so i'm in the early pro processes of
that
that's exciting are you excited are you
nervous or
are you just kind of there i feel the
stakes are fairly low for me because
i um i already have like four or five
finished songs that i just built a vocal
booth in my
uh house and um and they sound great i'm
really proud of them
the the cool thing is that i don't have
a label or anyone that like put put this
together so i don't have any
anyone that i'm trying to impress
specifically it's all coming just for me
and it's fun it's top 40
sounds like bieber love the weekend
uh there's like a maroon 5 aspect to one
of the songs
um and it's just it's just like uh you
know because i was like gosh if i write
an album
do i do what do i do how do i sound like
because i got i do so many different
kinds of genres but i think
i like to listen to music with good
lyrics
this movie was so much fun and i love
that your character's power
is to clone so i want to know if you had
that superpower in real life how would
you use that for good
if i could clone in real life how could
i use that for good well i would get a
lot
my my house would be cleaner uh i just
think i just think that all of us
schuylers would divide and conquer
i mean uh whether that would be
charitable work you know
going door to door you get a lot more
done there um
you know uh you get to try we would
travel i think we'd be quite the team
uh i think we'd all get along i somewhat
say we'd be like-minded
uh i i uh i i think the the the
opportunities are
endless i mean you could put out fires
literally and figuratively in so many
different ways
if you had so many more of you i like
that you thought about that that's good
um so you know reading the script you
know looking at all the different
characters why are you so excited to be
part of this project
well i just thought that it was a fun
ride first of all yeah and then second
of all when i actually like got into the
nitty-gritty of the script i realized
that it was really about
inclusivity and coming together finding
your purpose
um teamwork uh for a common enemy
which like we are all facing in many
ways a common enemy right now
and and we see um the importance of
wearing a mask and staying safe and
things like that it's a it's a palpable
thing and
uh playing sports as a kid but having my
father who was a coach
as a kid i do know the importance of
teamwork and
and um you know ensemble when i did
theater too so i just love
i love being able to reflect that on
screen and um not to like call them kids
but like they're the cast is so good in
this
yeah oh i mean they're they are young
talents with their entire careers ahead
of them uh
it was really fun to work with i worked
with each and every one of them and
a lot of them and now you've seen the
film uh one on one and
um you know uh uh going from working
with peyton
lee one on one where we're kind of
having this really meaningful teacher
student scene
and then i go to the next set over where
olivia and i
uh who plays princess roxanna uh we have
a scene that's
really like adult comedy like repartee
like we're doing improv um i feel
you know like i'm completely standing
opposite someone who's done this for
years and years and years and the thing
is a lot of them actually even though
they are kids have been doing this for
years and years
it's true yeah but yeah no i was just so
impressed with everybody in this okay so
i have a couple seconds left
most important question being that this
movie uh is about
second-born royals with superpowers do
you think prince harry has a superpower
ooh uh yeah i mean prince harry's got
his own thing going on i mean i have
great respect for it
i mean i don't know if i would want to i
don't know what's going on in his
specific kingdom
but like you know uh i i would try to
influence change in my kingdom if it
were
if it were possible i don't know what
he's up against in his world but i
always respect someone
who chooses their own path and it seems
like that's what prince harry is doing
and you know what
maybe he can teleport i don't know
that would be awesome